le conseil municipal a voté à
l'unanimité une motion demandant le
maintien d'alstom sur son site
historique de belfort alstom qui prévoit
de transférer la production d'alsace
ils ont payé 12 milliards les américains
et sur les 12 milliards il ya eu 4
milliards 800 millions pour
l'augmentation des dividendes des
actionnaires d'alstom née du rachat
d'actions et symphonie de poursuites en
justice
alstom sa emblématique du constat
d'échec de toutes les politiques
libérales qui ont été menées par des
gouvernements de droite comme de gauche
y compris quand arnaud montebourg y
était d'ailleurs par exemple mail vous
sont assez remontés contre françois
hollande oui mais y'a de quoi
franchement il ya de quoi écouter quand
on sait le président l'a public qui
s'est levé premier responsable 1 c'est
pas le premier ministre les ministres le
priant un public dans notre constitution
qui est le premier responsable et c'est
lui qui s'est montré très raide sur la
loi travail par cette mobilisation elle
est là pour dire c'est pas un baroud
d'honneur le baroud d'honneur ça
voudrait dire quoi ce héros mobilise
aujourd'hui apprendront à la maison n'en
parle plus non on va continuer à traiter
le dossier je vous le dis on va agir à
tous les niveaux possibles voilà on se
prive d'une centrale comme fun il y aura
des problèmes de d'énergie et ça peut
créer de l'emploi dans l'industrie des
bougies peut-être mais c'est ça la
réalité après propos clairement
climato-sceptiques l'ancien président a
des doutes sur l' influence de l'homme
dans le réchauffement climatique les
phénomènes de ce genre la planète on a
connu dit il ça ne veut pas dire qu'il
ne faut pas s'en occuper l'homme n'est
pas le seul responsable comment nicolas
sarkozy peut-il mieux savoir que toute
la communauté scientifique qui
aujourd'hui est d'accord l'activité
humaine portent une lourde part de
responsabilité dans la production c'est
donc le réchauffement climatique le
billet seigner une réalité moi je me
souviens de nicolas sarkozy au grenelle
de l'environnement disant que désormais
plus aucune grande politique publique ne
pouvait se faire sans intégrer la
question du changement climatique par le
déclin de la biodiversité la santé
environnementale tel est l'ordre des
priorités que j'ai fixé ce n'est pas une
question de confort et je veux le dire
aux français c'est une question de
survie moi je ne crois pas qu'il faille
renier ses convictions pour pouvoir
conquérir des électeurs et parce que ça
pouvait s'agir je passe à ce qu'ils
peuvent dire que l'homme n'a aucune
responsabilité dans le réchauffement
climatique je crois que c'est une grave
erreur que de dire ça donc oui il faut
protéger la planète oui il faut lutter
contre les dérèglements climatiques
non l'homme n'est pas le seul
responsable des dérèglements climatiques
j'ai retrouvé les caméras de
surveillance de france 2 nicolas sarkozy
est arrivé il au parking c'est lui et il
est même d'accord au maquillage
et il faut se préoccuper de toute
urgence du grand défi qui est lié au
défi environnemental la démographie
c'est votre nouveau défi
et